sirvió de alguna manera el discurso de
macón Para calmar los ánimos dijo que la
puerta está abierta pero esta puerta no
lo estuvo para los sindicatos durante el
proceso de aprobación de la ley
bueno exactamente esta puerta no estuvo
abierta y hoy día vimos según Emanuel
un tono
respecto al cual no estoy segura de que
haya logrado restablecer un poco la
empatía que esperaba el juego francés
respecto a esta educación por si
esperaba algo no porque había también
hubo también mucho movimiento en la
calle había un llamado a boicotear y no
mirar la locución por lo tanto ya hay un
divorcio entre Manuel y la calle y no sé
si el el tono fue fue necesariamente muy
positivo en ese sentido considerando que
él se felicitó por por su su balance
tiene resultados muy positivos en en
relación a la reducción del desempleo
sino lugar a dudas habló también de la
red industrialización del país que daba
señales positivas entonces
en una en una de esas no no era
necesariamente lo que lo que se esperaba
de todas maneras tampoco tenía tenía
mucha opción la medida en que la reforma
fue aprobada y por lo tanto va a seguir
adelante el mensaje también que él
transmite en esa locución es que
precisamente no inmovilismo va a seguir
adelante con su quinquenio y ofrece un
paquete de medidas que no son todavía
muy concretas pero anuncia
seguir en las grandes reformas que
requiere el país eso es un poco la el
aporte finalmente fundamental de de la
locución con tres grandes frentes no una
un frente
del trabajo en relación con el trabajo
en Que obviamente ahí toca un punto
fundamental para los franceses que se el
hecho de que la pauperización un poco de
la vida en relación a también lo que la
gente gana el sueldo mínimo en Francia
es uno de los más elevados de Europa
pero el salario mediano se acerca
también bastante más que en los este
sueldo mínimo entonces que hay ahí una
una propuesta de un poco reconstruir o
repensar esta relación al trabajo
conjuntamente con los sindicatos Bueno
luego tuvimos todo el orden republicano
un discurso bastante bastante
afín la sensibilidades más de de de de
Centro derecha principalmente con
reforzar el funcionamiento de la
justicia la gendarmería etcétera y todo
lo que tiene que ver con el progreso
para vivir mejor con el foco en dos
temas que son fundamentales para los
franceses educación y salud considerando
que tenemos un estado de bienestar que
está
erosionándose y que hay mucha demanda
también de mejora de los servicios
públicos que no están cumpliendo con lo
que lo que se espera de ellos
últimamente Más allá de la necesidad que
Argumenta el gobierno fue un error haber
aprobado esta reforma sin debate
legislativo
bueno fue fue un error Pero por otro
lado
bueno el presidente no tiene la mayoría
tiene una mayor relativa en el congreso
él quería dejar una gran reforma en su
segundo quinquenio que es esta reforma
que por supuesto que es percibida como
una reforma necesaria no es una una
reforma que no sea moderada si uno toma
como contrapunto a los demás países
europeos donde se trabaja más sino la
edad de jubilación es más tardía que en
el caso de Francia Entonces por supuesto
que hay todo ahí
Bueno
este planteamiento es bien es bien
fundamental
porque releva todo el déficit del
sistema de reparto etcétera
brevemente el consejo constitucional
rechazó la primera solicitud de
referendo pero estudiará el 3 de mayo
una segunda petición planteada con una
cuestión diferente qué se puede esperar
al respecto
no sé si mucho en la medida en que si
rechazó la primera solicitud por un tema
de incongruencia jurídica
la primera es más aceptable Pero por
otro lado se nota un presidente que
quiere seguir adelante y un consejo
constitucional que parece haberlo
apoyado en esa en esa voluntad de
reforma